good morning Hank it's Tuesday I was
gonna make a video about Fahrenheit 451
but then after your video on Friday I
was like I'm gonna talk about the
controversial rationale for why capital
gains should be taxed at a lower rate
than income but all that is going to
have to wait because Hank there is a
pressing question in our community
specifically the question of where it is
best not to vomit in a recent video I
talked about when I worked at Steak and
Shake and how I had to sometimes clean
vomit out of urinals at a nerdfighter
wrote worse place to puke ever yeah well
no in fact let me submit that there are
at least five worst places to vomit than
in a urinal the worst place to vomit is
clearly into your own lungs because that
can be fatal aspiration of vomits would
kill Jimmy headaches but it's also
killed lots of other nice people so yeah
don't vomit into your lungs
okay another place you don't vomit and I
have personal experience with this is in
a secret hiding place so Hank once when
I was in high school I was at a party
and for reasons that we don't need to
get into I needed to vomit also for
reasons we don't need to get into but
this is important to the story I wasn't
operating it like 100 percent of my
intellectual capacity so I needed to
throw up but I didn't want anyone to
know that I needed to throw up and this
house had Benson the floor where the air
conditioning came out of so I found a
quiet corner and I took off one of those
vents and I puked into it problem solved
right yeah except not because it turns
out that when you puke into ductwork the
smell of that puke like circulates
through the entire home also it turns
out it's really hard to clean puke out
of ductwork and sometimes part of the
air ducts must be replaced at a cost of
hundreds of dollars and you'll never
guess who will be held financially
responsible for that the puker in my
experience the puker is held responsible
number three you don't want to vomit in
space vomiting in space is a big problem
because your inner ear doesn't know what
to do about the floatiness in fact after
guarantee Taub became the second person
in space and the first one to vomit
there the Soviets shut down their space
program for a year because they couldn't
figure out why space sickness was
happening lots of astronaut sins have
reported puking and obviously it's
really gross if you don't get it in the
bag because it's all floaty but it could
also be fatal if you vomit while wearing
a spacesuit because of vomit aspiration
fortunately nASA has solved this problem
by creating air currents around the face
of the spacesuit that will push the
vomit away I love NASA of course you
still have to hang out with your puke as
long as you're in the spacesuit which
only makes you more likely to keep
puking I figure if you put me on a
spacewalk for like 30 minutes by the
time I came back it would be like half
John half vomit number four this also
comes from
working in restaurants you don't want to
puke on a bathroom mirror
I used to bus tables at this restaurant
and one time somebody puked on the
mirror and I had to clean it and I went
in there and it's not just that there's
the puke there's also the reflection of
the puke and in this particular bathroom
had a side mirror so there were like
infinite reflections of the puke going
on for eternity but then of course as
you're cleaning you've also got your
face reflected in the mirror and it's
pockmarked with someone else's puke
which makes you puke but you haven't
learned your lesson in high school about
we're not to puke puke in the toilet
like a grown-up sorry I'm very
passionate about this and lastly the
place aside from your own lungs that you
want to puke the least on to another
person I think you're probably sitting
there in missoula thinking I've never
puked on someone well I want you to do
me a favor call our parents and thank
them because you did puke on them
repeatedly I know this because children
are always puking onto their parents
Henry ones puked into my half-open mouth
I was just holding him up like this and
I was like you are such a cube oh my god
what just happened to me nerdfighters
just a word of advice whenever you're
furious with your parents or you think
they're terrible just remember you
vomited on them and they kept you so
there you have it Hank five places you
really don't want to vomit for those
nerdfighters who've been like are they
only gonna make like profound videos now
how do you like these apples
best wishes Hank I'll see you on Friday